Det betyder ju bara att man gör allt.
Men vad gör en CMO på riktigt?
Du som ändå har den rollen, och gissningsvis verkligen blev rekryterad för den rollen, vad gör du?
Nu låter du rösten som min far.
Du egentligen hela dagarna.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Chernobyl-generationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har redan dess bra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger...
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Ulrika Klinkert från Rugvista till podden.
Det är första gången vi har med någon från ett börsnoterat bolag.
Det är för att generellt sett tenderar de människorna att vara obörnhörligt tråkiga att lyssna på, för att de säger ingenting och det blir väldigt slätstrukigt.
Men jag har sett Ulrika live när hon pratade och det var faktiskt konkret, till skillnad från alla andra.
Ingen slängde under bussen, men typ alla andra.
Därför tyckte jag att det var ett väldigt passande inslag i podden.
Välkommen Ulrika, stämmer det?
Tack så hemskt mycket, vilken otrolig komplimang.
Jag hoppas att jag kan vara konkret.
Jag försöker i alla fall göra det när jag pratar, jag tar det så positivt.
Kan du ge oss lite kort bakgrund om dig?
Du har ju en riktig karriär.
Ja, riktig vet jag inte.
Det jag har gjort är att, om man tittar på vad jag är, det är en värmlandstös som hamnat i Skåne efter lite omvägar.
Jag är ingenjör från bakgrunden men hela tiden rört mig i marknads-svären.
Så att marknad med digitala företräkare är det jag.
Tittar man på det hela, alltså allt med teknik och marknad ihop, det är det jag gör.
Så jag har jobbat med godis på företag som idag heter Cluetta, varumärket som Agriens Bilar läcker åt sedan de har fått till.
Jag har jobbat med Shadow Company när vi skulle lansera vår första webbsätt eller e-handelsplattform.
Jag har varit på spelbolag, och nu är jag med i mattindustrin.
Har du varit på något bolag som folk inte känner igen?
Ja, jag började på ett företag som heter Airly Kid.
Känner du till det?
Nej.
Säljer gas?
Jaha okej, nej.
Så att likadant, ett företag som då hette Nech, det var Framfabs, i glada 2000-talet, då alla skulle jobba med webb.
Då hette det företaget Nech.
Uppsomsol, ner som pannkaka.
Jag förstår, det var den gamla goda tiden.
Vad är det du är, om man får uttrycka sig så, vad är det du är duktig på?
Jag är duktig på...
Det är alltid svårt att säga, man själv är duktig på.
Får någon annan säga?
Nej, du har hört någon på podden.
Det här är en skrytzon, här får man liksom vara sig själv.
Ja, nej, det jag brinner för är konsumentinsikter, att kunna förstå kunden och, och det låter jättefloskligt men, att se behoven och kunna sälja på det.
Ja men, det är en skrytzon.
Introtterat, nu kommer ni få svar som ni aldrig har fått från en annan börsbolag.
Förstå kunden och, nej, men, det handlar om.
Ja, det handlar om i slutändan.
Kan vi ta lite kort vad Ragvista är?
Jag känner till det, jag har faktiskt haft aktier i det bolaget under lång tid.
När du började, det är en aktieresa, men ja, vi är ju inte alltid börsnoterade, så tar man från början, och då får jag nästan börja med en fråga som man får från alla.
Carpet Vista och Ragvista, vad är det för skillnad egentligen?
Det började faktiskt 2005 som Carpet Vista.
Och vill man ha lite mer kuriosa, så då, varför heter det Vista?
Och då tar vi just tillbaka till 2000-talet.
2005 startade Carpet Vista.
Och då fanns det ju en sökmotor som hette Alta Vista, den som är riktigt gamla.
Så att Carpet Vista är ju då från ovan sökmotor när det gäller carpets.
Så det är lite om namnet.
Så Carpet Vista var då äkta mattor, handknutna persiska mattor.
Sen 2011 började Ragvista och det var då maskingjorda mattor, för att man såg att det var två helt olika kunder som var på de olika sajtarna.
Plus då kunde man ju faktiskt jobba lite mer med Google.
Vi hade vår egen sökmotor, så du kunde bestämma när kunden skulle se vilken av sajtarna.
Så du fick ju bättre site impressions på serpen egentligen.
Men sen så slog de här två sajtarna ihop.
2016 ungefär la vi alla mattor på Ragvista.
Och sen när vi börsnoterades 2021 så valde vi också att byta företagets namn till Ragvista.
Och det är egentligen bara man kunde välja vilken namn.
Allt det kallas man rags eller corpets, men SCO-mässigt är rags större än corpets.
Men var Ragvista ett e-handelsbolag redan från start?
Ja redan från start, vi har bara varit online.
Inte haft butiker, vi har haft några butiker, men det har mer varit för att kunna vara online.
Jag kanske ska berätta lite mer, ja vi säljer mattor, vi har bara fokus på mattor.
Men när vi säger mattor så är vi verkligen i en nisch.
Man kan ju säga hemmindredning, men i hemmindredning finns det mattor så det är väldigt smalt.
Men inför det säljer vi mattor som kostar 300 kronor som en badrumsmatta eller en miljon drygt som är en fin persisk mattal.
Så vi har verkligen extrem bredd på vårt sortiment.
Ja och ändå är det egna mattor?
Det är egna mattor.
Största delen av mattorna som vi säljer är egen designade.
Givetvis de som är persiska, de har ju gjort, vissa är ju 300 år gamla och har gjort sig på samma sätt flera hundra år.
Så de är ju designade så som en isfahan-matta eller en tablismatta alltid har gjorts.
Men huvudsakligen av de andra mattorna designar vi själv, så vi har vår egen designstudio.
Och det är faktiskt en av de största missuppfattningarna.
Man tror att vi är en marknadsplats eller en återförsäljare för andras mattor, men det är våra egna mattor som vi säljer online.
Om det är en största missuppfattning är det inte lite under ditt gebit att ändra om den missuppfattningen?
Jo, det är det och det är något som vi jobbar med väldigt mycket, så absolut, det är vår plan.
Jag fattar.
Men jag är fascinerad när man drog igång det 2005.
Det var lite udda att sälja böcker online.
Att sälja mattor som en bedrövlig logistik måste ju ha varit en rätt konstig affärsidé att börja 2005.
Det är stora köp och sällan köp.
Det var också en av anledningar till att vi gick och jag var inte med då.
Jag har varit på Ragnista i drygt sju år.
Så hade jag ju 20 år så det hände saker innan jag kom hit.
Men när vi började så var idén också att komma ut i så många marknader som möjligt.
Genom att du köper en matta, cirka var tredje år, lite drygt, så tar det ganska lång tid innan kunden kommer in igen.
Så får du volym i det hela så måste du gå ut på flera marknader för att få en affär i det.
Men ja, det var inte många som trodde på de två killarna som startade det då.
Det var en matt-grussist och en tech-person som byggde hela vår tech-plattform som gick ihop och startade det här.
Gick det bra från start eller var det där rätt knaggligt i tio år?
Jag bara tänker hur historien har sett ut.
Som jag har förstått det så gick det, visst första åren är det ju alltid att det är lite knaggligt i början, men ganska snabbt så gick det bra.
Anledningen till det, till skillnad från, och vi kommer säkert prata om det senare men, när du köper en produkt så pass sällan, så måste även det första köpet vara lönsamt.
Sätter du upp hela affärsmodellen att första köpet ska vara lönsamt, så blir det ju faktiskt lönsamt.
Visst då har ju en större kostym i början som du måste täcka innan du fått in alla köpen.
Men från början var det en egenutvecklad produkt, så det var ett litet företag som sen växte organiskt över tid.
Så vi har varit lönsamma i stort sett hela tiden.
Hur funkar produktionen idag?
Äger ni grejer eller jobbar ni med massa olika leverantörer i olika länder?
Ni är på så många marknader och det måste vara ganska olika nischer.
Förvånansvärt lite olika nischer.
Det som skiljer är, visst, färger skiljer jättemycket mellan länder.
Kommer i Sydeuropa så är det ganska mycket färg.
Här uppe i Norden är vi ganska bärsa och ljusa.
Men typer av mattor, mixen är relativt likt, oavsett vilka marknader du är på så att det är egentligen inget problem för oss.
Sen har vi olika leverantörer som du säger.
Vi har leverantörer i Indien, vi har leverantörer i Europa, vi har mattor som vi designar själv, kontrollerar vi ju hela ledet så att säga.
Så jag skulle inte säga att det är något problem landsmässigt.
Eftersom vi har vår egen täckplattform så kan vi styra precis hur det landet ska se ut mot det behovet.
Finns det något land som sticker ut och är sådär, här köper de bara, jag vet inte, jag kan ingenting om matte men du vet.
Nej och det kunde inte jag heller innebörja här.
Mamma blir nerd, alltså jag är så mattnörd så det finns inte.
Men om man tittar generellt, Frankrike är en marknad som har mycket mer färgglada mattor, mycket mer åt det orientaliska hållet.
Medan Norden igen, vi är ganska enkla i vårt sätt, hur vi dekorerar våra hem.
Så visst det påverkar.
Jag fattar, jag tänker om vi tittar lite på dig, du är CMO och jag tänker alltid när jag ser sådana här trebokstavsförkortningar.
Vad är det för någonting?
Ja exakt och framförallt tänker jag så när det står, om bolaget omsätter 10 miljoner, då tänker jag fan det betyder ju bara att man gör allt.
Men vad gör en CMO på riktigt?
Du som ändå har den rollen och gissningsvis verkligen blev rekryterad för den rollen, vad gör du?
Nu låter du nästan som min far.
Vad gör du egentligen hela dagarna?
Vad brukar jag svara?
Jag säljer matto.
Så säger mina föräldrar med.
Men det korta svaret är att vara en CMO, jag tycker egentligen, visst det är en titel men du jobbar med att förstå kunderna och att kunna tillfredsstära deras behov.
Men för min del, det beror på också när du tittar i resan och de bolagen jag varit i, är du ett mindre bolag så blir ju rollen mycket bredare och är du ett större bolag så blir den kanske lite mer strategisk.
Men tittar du på min vecka, det handlar egentligen om att sätta upp strategierna som vi vill framöver.
Hur om ett år, hur ska vi klara det här året?
Och sen så går du ner på olika projekt, hur ska de här då projekten som ska göra att vi ska ta oss till det målet se ut?
Så min vecka kan ju se ut att ja men på måndagen sitter vi och tittar på säljtalen, hur det gick för veckans försäljning, och då är du ju väldigt nert i detalj.
Sen sitter man med designteamet och ser vilka mattor vi ska lansera framöver för att kunna tillfredsställa kunden.
Sen sitter du med SEO, även om du säger att det är ett stort bolag och vi omsätter 700 miljoner, ja men det är inte så stor skillnad om det är ett litet eller stort bolag.
Vi är bara hundra personer som jobbar på röglista, så att alla pratar med alla.
Så det är väldigt mycket med det operativt.
Det är en galet, slimmad siffra av anställda.
Ja för då är det även inkluderat lagerpersonal och kundtjänst, så att det är en oro.
Vi har vår egen techplattform så är vi ju hela techteamet inkluderat där också.
Ja det är det, vi är slimmade.
Ja det var det jävligaste.
Jaha, 70 pers för hur många jobbar på lagret?
Det måste ändå vara typ 20-30 personer.
Ja och det beror, vi är väldigt säsongsbaserade, så vi säljer ungefär dubbelt så mycket i högsäsong som i lågsäsong, så där har vi en variabel del där vi tar in lagerpersonal men vi är slimmade.
Vi har inte jobbat, jaha vad roligt.
Okej, så på ett litet bolag så jobbar man ganska brett och på ett stort bolag så var det lite mer strategiskt, men det lät som att du jobbade ganska brett.
Det var inte många avdelningar du lämnade ut där.
Nej, under varje vecka så skulle jag säga att jag har kontakt med alla i hela bolaget hela tiden.
Det är så vi behöver jobba och man kan ju tycka att det låter lite men för att hitta en strategi, säg om vi ska vinna serien, så måste du hitta hur ska du vinna varje match och då måste du sitta och diskutera i dina grupper hur ska vi lösa det här problemet.
CRM är jätteviktigt, SEO är jätteviktigt, alla kanaler när vi sitter och tittar på performance marketing, vi måste veta vad vi kan öka och minska på det, vilken kanal vi kan öka och minska och vilken marknad vi kan öka och minska.
Vi är extremt på talen hela tiden.
Och du frågade lite vad är skillnaden med börsnoterat bolag och inte.
Det enda som egentligen är skillnaden är att vi kan inte dela alla siffror hela tiden.
Men annars har alla väldigt koll på alla delar vi gör.
Kan du känna att du har blivit hindrad i ditt strategiska arbete för att ni är börsnoterade, framförallt de senaste åren när det har varit e-handel har inte varit jätteälskat på börsen.
Då är det så här, vi har en tanke här om två år men det skiter folk som köper aktier i ganska mycket.
Då blir det strategiska väldigt tillbaka satt.
Eller tänker ni inte på det?
Det är klart vi som sitter med de kontakterna när man pratar med investerare eller liknande, det är primärt vd och CFO som gör det.
Men det viktiga för alla oss andra, gör vi inte en bra business och gör vi inte det som är bra för bolaget, så kommer ju ändå inte aktierna att gå bra över tid.
Jag går inte dagligen runt och tänker på hur aktien mår, för gör vi bra saker så kommer det över tid att bli bra även för våra aktieägare.
Men hur ofta kommer du aktien?
Varje dag.
Jag känner det.
Du sitter ju här i mycket möten.
Hur jobbar du som CMO?
Är du en strikt person och kräver in mycket siffror?
Eller är du med i nån sorts brainstorming sessions?
Eller är du mest som en påhejande person?
Vad är din personlighetstyp i den här rollen?
Jag skulle säga att det beror på, jag säger det hela tiden, men det beror faktiskt på vilken del i årscykeln du är.
Om du är i en strategisk fas, när vi ser vad vi ska göra det kommande året, då blir det mer workshops.
När är lågsäsongen?
Sommar.
Okej, ja.
Då ligger alla på stranden och man tänker inte på att oj nu när man kommer in på vintern så ser man shit här måste vi mysa till det och då blir en matta ganska bra.
Så att sen börjar faktiskt sommaren bli riktigt bra.
För att vi börjar möblera utomhus.
Många köper möbler som utomhus och då behöver du även matta utomhus så att sommaren börjar bli riktigt bra för oss också.
Men vintern är då du kosar in dig och behöver en lilla mysiga matta.
Jag fattar.
Men om vi tillbaks till din fråga kan jag svara, det är inte på den vilken typ av personlighet jag är.
Om vi tittar på vårt marknadsteam så är det tre olika delar.
Vi har vår performance marketing team.
Där är det otroligt mycket siffror.
Där är det inte så jättemycket workshop, utan då tittar vi på vilka kanaler behöver vi ha för att möta de kunder vi vill möta och hur fungerar de kanalerna ifrån och till varandra.
Väldigt mycket fakta.
Sedan har vi vårt own media team, det vill säga hur ser vår site ut, hur funkar CRM, hur funkar SCO.
Där är det lite mer både siffror givetvis, men hur vill vi visa våra produkter, vad tycker vi är viktigt att visa.
Så där är det mer inifrån och ut.
Sedan tittar du på det tredje benet, det kreativa team, där sitter liksom videograf, fotograf, allting som skapar det vackra som är i våra annonser på site.
Där är det mycket workshop.
Nu har vi en kampanj som ska gå om ett halvår.
Det handlar om rustic bohemian.
Hur ska vi visa rustic bohemian på ett så bra sätt som möjligt?
Då är det mer kreativt.
Det är faktiskt hela bredden och då måste jag anpassa mig till gruppen, men även till vilken del av fokus, om det är kortsiktigt eller långsiktigt.
Jag som är fördomsfull, om du är från ingenjörsbakgrunden, har du lättare att snacka performance marketing än känslor?
Jag behöver det, jag är väldigt glad att vi har ett väldigt starkt kreativt team.
Där behöver jag support.
Diplomatiskt.
Sen tycker jag det är väldigt roligt, jag tror generellt, särskilt, nu blir jag kanske lite filosofisk men, där världen är nu, där allting kan mätas, och särskilt performance marketing har vi ju kunnat mäta väldigt bra de senaste åren.
Nu kan vi mäta det mindre för vi har cookie policy och liknande.
Världen och kunderna och vi behöver mer det spirituella.
Och där tror jag att det kreativa har en väldigt, väldigt viktig del att man får det skönheten i livet också.
Jag köper det på ett filosofiskt plan men om du inte kan mäta att det ger en effekt så är det ju en svår grej.
Ja absolut och det måste vi ju mäta.
Vi mäter ju våra annonser hela tiden och sen testar vi olika.
Funkar det medel utan katt på mattan?
Funkar det medel utan människa på mattan?
Så det märks hela tiden.
Medel utan katt, men jag köper det, det är klart.
Det är så man ska göra.
Du sa att ni hade säsonger, eller du säger, men jag vill minnas att när jag var och lyssnade på det på den här föreläsningen så visst sa du att ni hade typ 42 marknader eller någonting?
Ja, det beror lite på hur man definierar en marknad.
Vi har sajter som är lokaliserade på olika språk.
På 22 marknader, vi ändrade det, om det är 22, det ändras hela tiden.
Inte hela tiden, men vi går i fler marknader.
Sen har vi dotcom, på dotcom kan du ju då köpa från andra marknader också.
Så jag skulle säga att aktiva marknader kan köpa från som i någorlunda volym cirka 30.
Men blir det så säsongsberoende?
Är det för att ni befinner er i någon samma...
Visst var ni även i typ Japan och Sydkorea eller så här, lite udda på andra sidan?
Japan är ju annorlunda då.
Sydkorea har vi faktiskt nu packat utifrån.
Vi gjorde en entry där som inte vi var lite...
Vi trodde det skulle gå lättare än vad vi trodde det egentligen blev.
Så vi har packat ut från Korea för att vi vill fokusera på Europa just nu.
Vi har jättemycket att vinna på Europa fortfarande.
Så Korea kanske är framöver men just nu är Europa det absolut viktigaste.
Men Japan, ja vi finns i Japan.
Där har det ju ett helt annat säsong.
Men man kan ju tycka att Japan, vilken typ av mattor behöver du ha?
Det är ganska kallt.
Så många i Japan har ju då golvvärme.
Så man har ju då mattar på mattar.
Så då har man värmemattar och så har man mattar på det.
Så många mattor som vi säljer till Japan är ju väldigt tjocka mattor.
För det är väldigt kallt.
Så det är en annan typ av produkter som går bra.
Sen väljer vi också då till Japan att inte gå med de absolut billigaste mattarna för att då får vi inte upp affären med frakt.
Ja ni skickar fortfarande allting från...
För Europa är liksom det den stora bulken och sen är...
Stora bulken.
Alla mattor går från Malmö.
Jaha vad häftigt.
På Sättland.
Är det, det kanske du inte får svara på men är det tanken även framöver eller?
Ja jag kan ju svara på det med tanke på att idag så har vi huvudkontoret är i kombination med ett lager.
Sedan blev det för litet då öppnade vi ett till lager.
Sedan blev det för litet då öppnade vi ytterligare ett lager.
Så nu har vi tre stycken lager och det har vi fram till att vi, vi har ett palett och bygger nytt kontor just nu.
Det kommer då samla alla de här mattorna på ett ställe.
Så med tanke på att vi bygger det så hoppas vi att det kan hålla oss ett tag.
Jag förstår hur stort är de här tre lagerna?
Jag älskar i lager, jag fattar att 90% tycker det är skittropigt.
Jag tycker det är lika som finns.
Och jag är inte den att kunna kvadratmeter.
Vad kan du inte kvadratmeter?
Men det är ju som du säger, det är ju väldigt bulka produkter.
Så det är ju klurigt.
På ett sätt är den absolut bästa e-handelsprodukten.
För du behöver ju inte se i märken mattar som du behöver med Hemellekspelning om man jämför med Kjell & Company.
Du behöver ingen instruktionsbok hur du öppnar den, det är bara att rulla ut den.
Men den är ju stor och bökig och bulkig.
Men den går ju inte sönder i frakten för att den är mjuk.
Så det är många fördelar förutom vikten som gör det så hårt att e-handla med mattor.
Ja, vi har ju lite samma, det är inte våra grejer som går sönder om de slår emot någonting utan det är ju...
Nej, ni har ju......de andra sidans liksom.
Så jag förstår precis problematiken och fördelarna där.
Jag tänkte på, när jag gick igenom din CV-lista här innan så såg jag att du...
Du är ju en sån där person som jag inte brukar anställa.
Då ska jag inte ge mig 10...
Jag gillar att anställa folk som har jobbat 15 år på en arbetsplats och sen går de till nästa arbetsplats.
Men du har varit liksom tre år på dem tidigare.
Sen har du varit ganska länge på Ragvista.
Kan du inte...
Är det bara att du blev vuxen där och...
Du bara, nej nu ska jag landa i livet eller...
Eller vad var det som gjorde att det här var liksom roligt?
De ställen jag varit längst på...
Jag var nio år på då hette det Malakbo, Cluetta.
Goddyskomponit.
Och så länge jag är på en arbetsplats där jag känner att jag kan bidra med och det händer saker, där kan jag stanna.
Om jag jämför när jag började på då, Corpet Vista, vilket var i slutet av 2017, så var min roll extremt bred.
Jag satt och förhandlade leveransavtal med Bartby och liknande, så satt jag med leveransledet.
Jag satt med avtal mot Klana, och likadant när jag började var vi en person på marknadsavdelingen.
Idag är vi nästan 20, bara på marknad och försäljning.
Vi ser marknad och försäljning som samma sak, vi har ingen butiksled.
Så länge jag känner att jag kan bidra, och du sa det i början, jag älskar ju Rög Vista.
Det är så otroligt mycket som vi har kvar att göra.
Vi är stora, men resan vi har framöver oss, vi har precis börjat skrapa på det som finns därute.
Och tittar du på kunden idag, så majoriteten av kunder köper ju fortfarande matta i butik, vilket är extremt onödigt för att det är så otroligt mycket lättare att göra det online.
Men du slipper inte öka med högar och du slipper få mattan som i bilen.
Det är tungt att öka så att så länge jag känner att jag kan bidra så stannar jag.
Under den här perioden så har ni ju vuxit, som du nämnde, ditt ansvar har vuxit sjukt mycket.
Men kunde du detta innan?
Kom du in här och kände att jag ska jobba upp bolaget till min nivå nu?
Eller vad har du lärt dig under tiden?
Vissa delar hade jag med mig.
Varumärkesdelen har jag gjort både inom flötta svären och telecompanysvären.
E-handel hade jag också med mig från telecompanysvären på ett helt annat sätt.
Telecompanysvären var ju enbart i en marknad då, och Corrupt Vista då var ju många fler marknader.
Så vissa delar har jag lärt mig under tiden, andra har jag tagit med mig.
Vi småfolk, vad gör vi för fel när vi sätter varumärke?
Ni etablerar varumärke hårt och snackar om det liksom, men vad är det vi mindre inte fattar när det kommer till varumärke?
Jag tror inte att ni inte fattar det, men om man tittar på olika delar när man säger sätta ett varumärke, för mig är det, dels handlar det om kännedom, det är att folk ska veta att du finns.
Men det kan ju vara ungefär som att säga att du ska gå ut på en date, men du måste ju veta att här finns jag.
Men att du ska bli vald, det handlar ju om varumärke.
Så styrka ni ett varumärke, okej?
Jag vet att du finns, men jag väljer dig medvetet val.
Det handlar ju inte om hur mycket media du lägger in, utan att det du säger är relevant till din kund, så att du kan vara jätteliten och vara superrelevant mot din kund.
Så det handlar ju om matchen mellan kunden och varumärket.
Det är egentligen inte storleken, utan finns den där så har du ett starkt varumärke.
Det måste finnas en viss svårighet där för det.
För jag tänker att om du tar Cloetta, jag tar det för att det vet väl alla vilka det är typ.
Men då är det såhär, ja det är gott.
Du vet, du går i affären och det ska kännas spontant, bara jäkligt gott.
Och så tänker man Sverige, så känns det bra.
Men jag köpte det här typ.
Men om jag ska köpa en matta, och ni har så pass olika matte från en badrumsmatta till en stor persisk matta, det är ju ganska olika kundgrupper på det där och det måste vara ganska olika.
Hur menar du att ni sätter varumärket mot er kundgrupp i den diversifieringen?
Du säger att vi små var gör vi för fel.
Du pratar ju helt rätt.
För det handlar om, vi har fem stycken, det finns många målgrupper, men vi har valt ut fem målgrupper som är våra målgrupper.
Och där måste du hitta buspen mot just den målgruppen.
Vi har tre stycken saker som vi trycker på i våra olika kommunikationskanaler.
Det beror på var finns målgruppen.
Dels måste det vara enkelt, vi pratar om convenience.
Det är en typ av målgrupp som tycker det är absolut viktigaste.
Rund, röd, matta, enkelt att hitta, enkelt att frakta.
De har familj och barn och allt annat.
Det ska bara vara enkelt.
Så där är du demot dem.
Sen har du the premium shopper.
Där är kvalitet otroligt viktig, varumärke otroligt viktig.
Där måste du ha storytelling, där måste du berätta.
Du ska nörda in dig.
Det finns en målgrupp som vi kallar The Carpet Connoisseur.
De vet ju exakt att en matta är tillverkad på det sättet och att den där lilla krummeluren som ser ut på ett visst sätt, varför de har gjort det.
Så där måste du nörda in dig.
Då pratar du på det sätt med dem.
Sen har du, vi kallar The visual shopper.
The visual shopper tycker att det är viktigt med hemmedledning, jätteviktigt, men de kanske inte tänker först på mattan.
De har sett hela rummet och då måste vi förklara varför kan matta hjälpa dig att göra det på det här sättet.
Varför ska du köpa matta istället för att måla om väggen.
Så att du måste prata på olika sätt till de olika kunderna.
Så vi jobbar jättemycket med convenience, quality och inspiration.
Där kan vi prata om hur viktigt är det med tagline och inte.
Den sammanfattar på något sätt vad vi är.
Vi är Quality Robs Online.
Tittar du på till exempel, det finns ju många nya aktörer som kommer från andra Asien och liknande som kanske inte är så mycket quality.
Vi vet ju när vi pratar med kunder att kvalitet är sjukt viktigt.
Sen betyder inte det att vi alltid ska ha den högsta kvalitén alltid.
Men för det prissegmentet du har, har du en badrumsmatta så ska vi aldrig gå under en viss nivå.
Du ska veta att köpte du oss så är det värde för det du köper.
Så vi kommer aldrig gå lägre än vad vi tycker är.
Det här är vi stolt över, det här är bra.
Sen ska det finnas hela prispandet.
Hur funkar det rent konkret?
Är det att ni riktar marknadsföring till de här tre olika modellerna?
Och när du kommer in på hemsidan hamnar du också i olika segment beroende på vem du är eller vart du har kommit in?
Eller försöker ni få med alla de här argumenten i samma?
Det är en av de delar vi jobbar mycket med framöver.
Vi är inte där än.
Vi har börjat med att göra det i externa kanaler.
Men på vår egen site visst vi tittar ju på vem är the browsing customer, vem är the searching customer så att du tillfredsställde alla dem.
Sen kan du jobba mycket mer och det behöver man alltid göra konstant att titta på vad just den här kundresan som den kunden behöver.
Och där har vi jobbat det senaste året.
För ett år sedan lanserade vi någonting som vi kallar Inspirationshubbel.
Så vi har ju otroligt mycket artiklar som vi skriver om våra mattar som vi då inte hade för ett år sedan.
För vi är ju väldigt Google-tunga.
Och där är det ju den mission driven customer som bara rundrar ett matta.
Den hittar jättebra hos oss.
Men den mer inspirerande kunden, den har vi mer att göra för.
Är det ett problem att...
För att matta är ändå en ganska dyr investering, eller det kan vara en dyr investering såklart, beroende på vilken matta du kollar på.
Men jag och min flickvän, vi tillhör ju de här två olika första grupperna.
Jag är ju aldrig mer än två klick från ett köp någonsin, för jag tar alltid den som kommer upp först längst till vänster, och i fall allt ser bra ut så klickar jag på den.
Medan hon kollar runt, sparar i olika varukorgar, väntar tills det kommer, ser om någon rea dyker upp där, kollar design där, om den stämmer med någon annan design, du vet såhär, det där.
Sen ska vi sammatcha sig i det på något sätt.
Det blir ju någon sorts halv gemensam, det är hon som bestämmer, men det blir ju någon sorts halv gemensamt beslut.
Tänker man även på den nivån eller skiter man i det liksom?
Nej, absolut på den nivån.
Det är så roligt att du säger att det är hon som bestämmer sig i slut.
Det ser vi också i nivådaten.
Han gillar inte vad jag har skönt.
Så det är inte en helt olika kundresa, men man skulle kunna ha en förutfattad mening att det är bara kvinnor som köper i vår kategori, det är det absolut inte.
Men inför de olika målgrupperna så har du olika bestämmare, så att säga beslutsfattare.
Jag tror vi alla förstår vad det egentligen betyder.
När du har jobbat med digitala tjänster, du har jobbat inom spelbolag till exempel, och det är ändå ett stort spelbolag.
Det är en helt annan värld, det är till stor del dagligt eller väldigt återkommande.
Det är snabbt och impulsdrivet, det är en helt annan marknadsföring, och man får inte göra viss marknad, det är så styrt och reglerat på det sättet.
Och sen gå till någonting som är sällanköpt och dyrt och eftertänksam.
Hur skiljer sig planeringen kring de där två eller strategin kring de två?
Finns det någonting som är lika och någonting som är olika?
Det som är lika skulle jag säga är att det handlar båda två om upplevelser.
Medan spelbolag är ju en tjänst egentligen som du tillhandahåller.
Nästan som en bank.
Du måste lita på tjänsten, du använder tjänsten.
Det är det själva upplevelsen av vad du gör.
Och det är mycket oftare.
Fördelen med att finnas i den världen är att du vet att du får ett upprepat köp flera gånger.
Så du behöver egentligen inte vara lönsam vid första interaktionen, utan du tittar ju på Customer lifetime väljer på ett helt annat sätt.
Tittar du på inför mattvärlden som jag pratade om i början, att vi vill ju vara lönsamma redan vid första köpet.
För att vi vet ju inte nästa gång kommer tillbaka, eller vi vet sådana att det tar en bra tid innan de kommer tillbaka.
Så det är två delar som är viktigt där.
Den första är om vi vet att de köper var tredje, var fjärde år, när vi väl har dem på kroken fast, då ska vi bara ta hem det köpet.
Så då gäller det att verkligen ta alla en hugg längs hela vägen, för att det tar så pass länge innan de kommer tillbaka.
Men den andra delen är ju att du kan göra en helt annan mediamix, som du sa att i spelvärlden så är det otroligt olika per marknad vad du får och inte får göra.
I mattvärlden så har du ju, det finns egentligen inga begränsningar vad du kan göra.
Du måste bara vara väldigt duktig på att veta vad de olika målgrupperna behöver för både kanalmix, men även för kommunikation.
Så på det sättet så tycker jag att det är lättare att arbeta i mattvärlden än i spelvärlden.
Men det som var också anledning till att jag var lockad av spelvärlden är att komma från cellokompani tidigare, då sitter de här långa, långa cyklarna.
Det måste ju också vara att man utvecklar en produkt, man beställer hem dem.
Det tar ett halvår innan de kommer hem.
Det är ju sjukt frustrerande medan spelvärlden kan du vara, det är sekunder från att du kan göra en kampanj.
Du kan ju inte göra en kampanj på samma sätt.
Du måste planera det mycket mer väl när du har en fysisk produkt.
Du pratade lite grann här om hooks, när ni har kunden inne på sidan, och så sa du att då får vi använda alla hooks vi kan.
Vad menar du med det?
Dels är det att använda alla våra verktyg som vi har.
Man kan ibland tycka att serien kommer alltid lite i sidodelen, men det är ett otroligt viktigt verktyg som vi har, både för att kunna prata med kunden från första interaktionen, för oftast lite beroende på vilket målgrupp, antingen köper du en matta på två dagar, då är man liknande så som du är, det ska ske snabbt.
Eller så har du en process som är tre månader kanske, från första tanken till att du ska köpa mattan, och då kan du påverka kunden längs hela den processen.
Då är det jätteviktigt att du har ett system där du kan följa kunden och bygga olika, det kan låta väldigt högtravande men nu, olika value proposition längs med hela resan, för du bygger på varför du ska köpa just den här mattan.
Har du lagt den som favorit i varukorgen?
Ja, det är klart du ska få information om den, precis som du sa att din fru gjorde och hade koll på.
Så där måste du också använda alla de delarna.
Känner ni ingen direkt uppföljning på kunder efter de har gjort sina köp, eftersom det är för långa tider, eller är ni ändå där och petar?
Absolut, vi är där och petar och det blör du lite på om du då är en subscriber eller inte.
Vi ser bra effekt av att inte bara prata, nu har vi den här igen, nu har vi den här igen, utan faktiskt i annan typ av information.
Visst vi pratar om nyheter, det gör ju alla, men även att utbilda kunden om olika, så här kan du ta hand om din matta, så här finns det olika stilar, det finns ju otroligt mycket i alla kategorier när du väl nördar in dig.
Så att olika typer av kommunikation längs med hela resan.
Men du nämnde att ni var rätt googeltunga, är det för att er produktsortiment är googeltungt, alltså mattor generellt är tungt, eller är det att ni är ett googeltungt bolag, alltså ni är inte så trendiga om du fattar vad jag säger.
Ni har inte hemma influens i världen, eller är det mer att ni ska röra i dit?
Hur tänker ni liksom kring hela den här hype-världen?
Det är en historisk del för vår del.
Jag pratade om i början att vi hade två varumärken, vi ville synas på Sarpen, vi hade en egen budmotor, vi har alltid varit väldigt googeltunga och det var en av våra fördelar i början.
Men det fanns inte så många mattföretag därute, så det var väldigt lönsamt.
Men nu när vi vill hitta andra målgrupper så måste vi gå och nå i andra kanaler.
För oss är det en resa att bredda vår mix för att hitta fler kunder i tidigare skede.
Istället för att de redan vet att de har en matta eller ska ha en matta, så fångar vi dem och påverkar dem att du kanske ska ha en matta istället för det här nya bordet eller mål om eller liknande.
Så hittar de tidigare i banan.
Är det att ni själva producerar sådant då eller är det att ni samarbetar med och ifall ni samarbetar med måste man tänka annorlunda som börsbolagen som ett litet privatdrivet företag med vilka man samarbetar med.
Alltså hur går era tankar kring samarbeten och liknande?
Vi gör faktiskt både och.
Vi producerar både vårt eget men vi jobbar definitivt med influencers.
Där vill vi matcha influencers mot vår målgrupp men även mot vi jobbar med kollektioner.
Om du ska köpa någonting annat, säg shampoo, så handlar det bara om hur du är som person.
Men när du har tittat på matto så finns det ju väldigt många olika stilar.
En kund vet ju ofta att det här är min stil hemma.
Men jag har ingen aning vilka matto som passar till min stil.
Så du måste hitta influencers som täcker de olika stilarna vi vill nå.
Har du en bohemisk stil, har du en klassisk stil, har du en skandinavisk stil.
Så det handlar egentligen inte om att vi är ett börsbolag.
Visst, vi kan ju inte ha för risky influencers för det kan ju bli fel.
Men det är snarare att matcha influencers stil.
Sen låter vi dem köra.
De absolut bästa influencers, de ger vi bara en matta och säger, det här är mattan, you go.
Alternativt att de själv säger, jag vill gärna ha den här mattan, can I go?
Ja, exakt.
Och då blir det som bäst.
Det här med, det jag absolut mest älskade med hela din föreläsning var när du pratade om marknader och du pratade om att ni batchade dem.
Jag har säkert hört det tidigare, men jag har aldrig greppat det konceptet innan, men det är jättelogiskt när du gick igenom det och du pratade här i olika typer.
Kan du berätta lite för oss om hur ni batchar marknader och hur era tänk går kring det där och varför och liknande.
Jag vet inte, jag kanske låter jättekolka, jag bara gillade det väldigt mycket.
Jag tror inte det är nåt nytt under solen för någon som jobbar med flera marknader.
Det är väldigt svårt, i alla fall om du är ett så pass litet team som vi är, att kunna göra lika mycket till alla marknader.
Så vi tittar ju på respektive marknad och ser A, hur stor är den marknaden?
B, hur lönsam är den marknaden för oss?
Hur många konkurrenter finns på den marknaden?
Hur tufft är det att ta sig in?
Har vi olika average or the value på den marknaden?
Många olika faktorer som gör att den marknaden får ett visst score hos oss.
Om det sen finns olika marknader som har liknande score så behandlar vi dem på samma sätt.
Och när vi säger batchar dem så får de olika fokus hos oss.
Till exempel att en marknad som är väldigt högprioriterad i den scoren, den ska få allt, den ska få den bästa SEO treatment, du gör alla dina 2-3 filter pil-piss precis som de ska vara, du gör det bästa content, du trycker lite mer, för vi budar ju per kanal och per marknad, du trycker lite mer i den marknaden.
Medan de som är kanske en B-tier eller C-tier, då kanske vi inte gör alla titlar precis, då har vi A i översättning på de marknader för good enough.
Medan de som är riktigt viktiga, då måste vi själv skriva de texterna, eller i alla fall se över det.
Så att beroende på vad du hamnar i den här skalan av hur viktig en marknad är, så behandlar vi de olika viktighetsgraden.
Vad är det som blir det aldrig fel, det där att vi bara lågprioriterar en marknad, det kanske fanns jättemycket potential.
Hur mycket testar ni en marknad innan ni avgör att det här är en B, eller det här är en C, eller det här är en A?
Är det inte en risk där?
Jo, det är en risk och att vi har så återigen tajta connection mellan teamen, så vi testar det konstant.
Egentligen hade vi velat titta på den här flustringen eller vatsningen en gång per kvartal för att se, men så här ser det ut nu för det ändras ju hela tiden.
Men vi gör ju kontinuerligt tester för att se att lyckas det här i den marknaden.
Tittar du på marknaden som Ungern, Rumänien, Tjeckien, det kanske är marknaden som inte får så mycket kärlek, men där tester vi saker hela tiden och ser hur långt kan vi gå nu med det här, då kanske bara ett utav benen, då trycker vi mer med budgeten men kanske inte trycker så långt i det som är content, för content tar ju väldigt lång tid att göra, men budget är ju ganska enkelt att skruva upp och skruva ner.
Så att där har vi, vi tittar på lönsamhet varje vecka, men vi testar ju hela hela tiden.
Spontant tänker man ju alltid att saker ska röra sig uppåt i cykeln, alltså mot A-tier, men märker ni någonsin att marknaden tappar istället?
Har ni haft en A-marknad som helt plötsligt bara, nej nu är den död?
Absolut.
Jag ska inte nämna några exempel på marknader, men marknaden som tidigare har varit väldigt högt prioriterad, så tittar vi på, men vänta ett tag, här ser return-rateen annorlunda ut, eller helt plötsligt sjunker average order value för att, just nu har den marknaden tufft för att ekonomin är tufft i den landet.
Ja men då får man ju, man ska inte säga backa, men man får ta det lite lugnt.
Så det gör vi absolut.
Ja, och hur gör ni när ni, om ni ska in i en ny marknad, hur avgör ni vilken marknad ni ska in i, och hur sker starttestet?
Starttesten, och det är förmodligen för att vi är så, vi är väldigt duktiga på Google, så vi startar alltid med Google för att stoppa tårna ner, händer någonting där.
Och sen efter det så lägger vi på de andra kanalerna, och sen får vi se hur mixen blir.
Kan vi gå tuffare i social eller måste vi dra ner där, för vi ser att vi måste ligga längre ner i fonden, så att ingen marknad har samma kanalmix som den andra.
Okej, jag tänker på det här med logistikkedjan.
Du nämnde Japan, det blir ett extremt exempel, så jag hoppar över det lite grann.
Men vi tar liksom Europa på något sätt, men det är en jäkla skillnad att gå från Malmö till Helsingborg och skicka ner en matta till södra Italien till exempel.
Hur beräknas fraktkostnader i det här, både för att ni har ganska skrymmande grejer, så det kan ju bli saker som skrymmer och det kan bli saker som inte skrymmer, det kan bli vikt och det kan bli...
Vi som jobbar inom logistik med den här förstår problematiken med...
Man kan inte bara ta att den väger 25 kilo, utan det är väldigt mycket annat som avgör också och den kan vara över en viss längd och helt plötsligt blir den dubbelt så dyr.
Det är tre centimeter.
Hur hanterar ni det mot kund?
Vi har valt att vara...
Det måste man komma tillbaka till för att kunna förklara hur vi har valt vår strategi.
Så måste man förstå, varför köper du inte en matta online mot att du vill gå till en butik?
Det är vårt största skifte, att hur får folk att köpa online?
Anledningen till att man inte köper online är att man vill känna och ta på matta.
Det är därför du helgår till butiken, vill du känna och ta på matta.
Så vi har sagt att vi får ta den kostnaden.
Det ska inte spela en roll för kunden om att den är stor eller liten, dyr eller inte, utan vi har fri frakt och fri eriturer på alla våra matte till alla våra länder.
Sen så blir ju då resultatet att vissa kategorier får en annan marginal än andra.
Och det är ju det vi kommer fram till, både vissa marknader blir ju då mer värt att pusha än andra marknader för att de är dyrare.
Men det möter vi själv internt.
Kunden märker aldrig det från sin sida.
Och sen för vår del, precis som du säger, det kan ju vara en matta som är väldigt fluffig, jättemycket hår på den och väldigt hög.
Så den är väldigt lätt när du får ihop den, men den är väldigt, väldigt bulkig.
Och där väljer ju vi då till exempel och liknande åt att det är otroligt svårt att frakta en lång matta.
För det är dyrt och jobbar du med DHL och alla så vill ju de ha en viss längd på en produkt, annat blir jättedyrt.
Fördelen med en matta, jämför med till exempel gymutrustning, att du kan ju faktiskt vika en matta.
Nästan alla mattor kan vikas till att bli det måttet som vi har som gräns för att vi då ska ha fri frakt och fri retur.
Vill du som kund av någon anledning ha den rullad istället, så får du då en kostnad för att du vill ha den rullad, för det är ju mycket dyrare att frakta det.
Men vi erbjuder alltid ett alternativ där du kan få den gratis, men då är den vikt, vilket gör att du får fram den.
Då får den väckmärken till att den har i tyg, så den fluffar till sig efter ett tag, men priset när du får upp den så har den ju väck.
Men betyder det att ni kan jobba fri?
Till exempel om ni har produkter som inte säljer så bra, kan ni rea ut dem hårdare på närliggande marknader, eftersom marginalen där på ett sätt då är mycket bättre.
Jobbar ni så?
Vi skulle kunna göra det, men än så länge så väljer vi att alla kunder i alla marknader ska få samma förutsättningar.
Det ska inte vara billigare på en marknad än en annan marknad.
Ni prisdiffar inte marknaden?
Nej, vi prisdiffer inte marknaden.
Det behöver inte betyda att det är så vi alltid kommer att göra, men än så länge så prisdiffar vi inte.
Jag tänker ibland blir saker liggande och då på ett sätt subventionerar lite närliggande marknader långt borta.
Det är bara fascinerande hur det funkar.
Men du kommer in i den batchningsteorin igen.
Då har du den marknaden som då, för då tittar vi på hela delen, kostar du att skicka till den marknaden så blir det plötsligt en C-marknad.
Det blir inte lika mycket i marknadsföringen.
Så det blir faktiskt justerande via den batchningen.
Slutligen är jag väldigt nyfiken på hur, om man kollar på de senaste, egentligen har vi gått igenom sex-sju år som har varit ganska weird, men jag gissar att ni, likt många andra, hade regerat bra under covid.
Stämmer.
Ja.
Sen gick vi in i lågkonjunktur och ni är en sällan köpsvara och gissningsvis också när man byter hus, så köper man mattor så att ni påverkas i allra högsta grad av att folk inte ville flytta runt heller.
Och folk var helt maniska i att inte vilja jobba med e-handel, det tog sig på börsen helt enkelt att värderingarna sjönk där.
Hur påverkar det som bolag?
Jag fattar att ni är långsiktiga, jag fattar den här vi ska göra det som är bra för bolaget, men det kan inte vara så lätt att stänga ut det hela det här.
Går du in på en break-it eller en e-handel.se eller dagens industri så kommer det att vara mörka grejer för hela e-handelsbranschen.
Hur hanterar man det och jobbar framåt och får med sig teamet och får med sig, jag är bara intresserad av hela hela kulturdelen av det.
Jag tror att det handlar jättemycket om att ha fötterna på jorden och veta vad du gör.
Även om man säger långsiktigt, ja det kan låta fina ord, men vi vet nästa steg vi vill göra.
Vi har så mycket i pipen så vi ser att det kan bli bättre.
Därför att annorlunda tänk om vi hade haft jättehög marknadsandel och vi bara kunde växa via marknaden.
Då har vi så mycket vi kan göra själva som gör att vi kan växa ut, oavsett hur marknaden ser ut runt omkring.
Så det känns som en väldigt bra och skön drivkraft att kunna ha.
Sedan har vi ändå haft lite fördelen i vår kategori.
Jag håller med dig, covid var fantastiskt för all e-handlare.
Sedan kom lågkonjunkturen, räntorna steg, elpriserna steg.
Fördelen med mattor när elpriserna stiger är att då tar folk ner energin i hemmet.
Det kostar ju med el.
Vad händer då?
Det blir kallare, golven blir kallare, fler folk behöver mattor, för då blir det mindre kallt.
Så jag har haft turen i oturen att kunna ha en produkt som faktiskt kan hjälpa folk att komma runt det man behöver komma runt.
Men så då har ni sett lite produktskillnad under den tiden också.
Men sen ska jag inte sticka understor med att visst det kundincentiv i de olika marknaderna, de är ju tuffare nu än att vara tidigare, folk håller ju pengarna.
Så att vi ser ju en skift mot något billigare mattor.
Sen kan vi påverka det väldigt mycket.
Du sa till, hur vet vi vilka mattor vi säljer när man kommer till vår site?
Vi kan ju själv välja vilka mattor vi lyfter.
Så att vi är ju själv vår egen lyckasprofet.
Exakt.
Men hade ni liksom när ni märkte att nu går vi mot inflation här, nu går vi mot lågkonjunktur, danerade ni för det scenariot då?
Eller var det mer att vi jobbar på som vi har gjort och så räknar vi att vi tar oss igenom detta?
Alltså hur sker skiftet där och hur mycket påverkade det egentligen?
Nej vi, jag ska inte säga att det lyckades komma väldigt samtidigt.
Tidigare har vi haft en portfölj som har varit dyrare mattor och vi lanserade i samband med Covid ett billigare sortiment som kallas Essentials.
Så den fanns ju redan på plats så att kunden kan välja annorlunda när du har den plånboken.
Men sen är det ju jätteviktigt att de mattorna inte tar över utan att när en kund kommer in och då vill ha, ja men jag vill inte bara ha en matta som ser bra ut men det är kanske lite lägre kvalitet.
Vi kan lyfta de andra också.
Och det beror på hur din relevans-engine är on-site, hur du merchandiser din site.
Så att, jag skulle, jag ser det inte, utifrån sätt får jag förstå vad du säger, att det är tufft att vara e-handlare och det är det.
Men vi får ju bara jobba mer effektivt med det vi kan.
Vi har så mycket som vi kan ändra framöver, både med hur vi blir bättre mot marknaden och vilka produkter vi lyfter fram.
Så att, nej det är inte svårt att motivera tiden tycker jag.
Gött att höra.
Ulrika, stort tack för din tid.
Fan vad spännande att få komma in i er värld här.
Tack, jag hoppas många fick med sig någonting.
Jag är ju aldrig mer än två klick från ett köp någonsin, för jag tar alltid den som kommer upp först längst till vänster, och ifall allt ser bra ut så klickar jag på den.